it's one of my favorite songs ever i  think like do you want to listen to it  sure like right now okay honestly it's  like kind of an acquired taste so if you  don't like like i totally get it okay  let's see i'll i'll just play you let's  see oh yeah a song that i've been  planning for this specific moment and i  think about all the time so okay  just play the song let me just i'm  rambling let me just play it for you  so the rest of the song sort of like  that you can kind of see where it's  going why'd you stop it i could just  tell from your reaction that you weren't  really into it this is like cool like  it's an acquired taste so like i can  tell you just like don't really get it  all right it's like i put my heart out  on a platter and you stabbed it  but it's cool